WINS HE WILL GIVE HIM A
CREEPY PORN PARDON.
>> Tucker: A HISTORY
PROFESSOR AT GEORGETTE
COLLEGE OUTSIDE OF ATLANTA.
THE KIND OF IMMIGRANT WE
WOULD WANT IN THIS COUNTRY.
IS HE HE
IS HE EE
IS HE EDUCATED AND KNOWS THE
ENGLISH WELL AND CARES A LOT
ABOUT WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
UNITED STATES, HIS NEW
COUNTRY.
PROFESSOR ZHU IS ALSO A
CRITIC OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
FOR THAT HE HAS BEEN
ATTACKED.
IT'S A THOUGHT CRIME.
SOME ARE CALLING FOR HIM TO
BE FIRED.
ONE LAWMAKER IN GEORGIA EVEN
VOICED PLANS TO WRITE TO HIS
COLLEGE TO VOICE QUOTE
CONCERNS ORWELLIAN TERM.
PRESIDENT ZHU SAYS HE WON'T
BACK DOWN AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
FIRST OF ALL I'M ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR WITH JOB SECURITY.
MY INSTITUTION HAS AN
ACADEMIC FREEDOM POLICY.
I TEACH STUDENTS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LEGAL AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
SO LUMPING LEGAL AND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION TOGETHER IS NOT
ONLY WRONG IT'S DEEPLY
OFFENSIVE.
IT'S LIKE LUMPING
PHARMACISTS AND DRUG DEALERS
TOGETHER AND CALLING AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT A QUOTE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT IS
LIKE CALLING A DRUG DEALER,
QUOTE AN UNLICENSED
PHARMACIST OR A STUDENT WHO
INTENTIONALLY CHEATED ON A
TEST A, QUOTE:  ANSWER KEY
BORROWER.
>> Tucker: IF I HAD A
PROFESSOR LIKE YOU IN
COLLEGE, I PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE LEARNED SOMETHING AND
ENJOYED IT.
WHAT DO YOUR KIDS SAY?
WHAT DO YOU'RE STUDENTS SAY
WHEN YOU PEEL OFF A LINE
LIKE THAT.
>> MOST OF MY STUDENTS ARE
AGAINST ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
I RESPECT EVERYONE'S
VIEWPOINTS.
I TELL STUDENTS YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BELIEVE ME.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE A
CONVINCING ARGUMENT, PLEASE
PROVIDE EVIDENCE.
>> Tucker: DO YOU PROVIDE
EVIDENCE TO BACK UP YOUR
POSITIONS ON IMMIGRATION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE HAVE BEEN NUMEROUS
STUDIES, HARVARD PROFESSOR
GEORGE HAS CONDUCTED THE
MOST IN-DEPTH STATISTICAL
ANALYSIS ON NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ON THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY AND HOW THAT
DIRECTLY LOWERS THE INCOMES
OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES,
THOSE R. WITH LESS THAN HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA IN THE UNITED
STATES.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
SO, FOR THE SAYING WHAT YOU
JUST SAID, BACKING UP AN
OPINION WITH EVIDENCE IN
THIS CASE BY HARVARD
RESEARCHER, SOME ARE SAYING
THAT YOU SHOULD BE FIRED
FROM YOUR JOB.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I
HAVE JOB SECURITY.
I'M AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR.
MY INSTITUTION HAS AN
ACADEMIC FREEDOM POLICY.
MY PERSPECTIVE IS EVERYONE
IS ENTITLED TO THEIR
OPINIONS.
I DON'T KNOW THIS LAWMAKER.
SHE DOESN'T REPRESENT ME.
I HAVE NEVER MET HER.
SHE CAN SAY WHATEVER SHE
WANTS.
SO SHE CAN CONTACT MY
INSTITUTION, APPARENTLY SHE
HAS SOME PRO-ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION FOLLOWERS.
I HAVE GOTTEN LOTS AND LOTS
OF MESSAGES.
MOST OF THEM ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTIVE.
I HAVE A FEW THAT DISAGREE
WITH MY VIEWS, BUT I RESPECT
EVERYONE'S OPINION.
EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO
FREE SPEECH.
>> Tucker: FIRST OF ALL, I
JUST WANT TO SAY, AGAIN, I'M
SO GLAD THAT YOU MOVED TO
THIS COUNTRY.
I ADMIRE YOUR BRAVERY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THERE IS
SOMEONE LIKE YOU STILL
TEACHING IN AN AMERICAN
UNIVERSITY.
WHAT DO YOUR COLLEAGUES
THINK OF YOU?
>> WELL, I THINK MOST OF MY
COLLEAGUES KNOW MY
ANTI-ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
ACTIVISM AND THEY UNDERSTAND
MY PERSPECTIVE AS A LEGAL
IMMIGRANT AND I FEEL LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES RESPECT MY VIEWS
AND I RESPECT THEIR VIEW.
>> Tucker: DO YOU REALLY
THINK THEY RESPECT YOUR
VIEW?
I HOPE YOU ARE RIGHT.
SO, WHEN YOU MOVED TO THIS
COUNTRY AND THEY TOLD YOU WE
HAD FREE SPEECH HERE YOU
TOOK THAT VERY SERIOUSLY.
I CAN TELL.
>> WELL, HERE'S WHAT I WILL
SAY.
I ALWAYS VOTE IN EVERY
SINGLE ELECTION.
I'M THE PROUD GEORGIA
REPUBLICAN.
I VOTE IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY.
AND I'M GOING TO WORK AS
HARD AS CAN I TO HELP MY
FRIEND CONGRESSWOMAN KAREN
HANDEL GET REELECTED IN 2020
IN THE GEORGIA'S SIXTH
DISTRICT.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK YOUR
COLLEAGUES ARE OKAY WITH
THAT, TOO?
>> WELL, IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT THEIR OPINIONS ARE.
I RESPECT THEIR VIEWS.
SOME OF THEM LIVE IN MY
DISTRICT.
SOME OF THEM DON'T.
I ASSUME MORE OF THEM ARE
LIBERAL.
SOME MIGHT BE MODERATE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I
RESPECT THEIR VIEWS AND THEY
UNDERSTAND WHERE I'M COMING
FROM.
AND I THINK THEY RESPECT MY
VIEWS.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS MORE
IMMIGRANTS LIKE YOU?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW BUT I
WILL TELL YOU THIS:  IN
OTHER COUNTRIES LIKE CANADA
THEY HAVE A MERIT BASED
POINT SYSTEM WHERE THEY GIVE
PRIORITY TO WELL-EDUCATED
LEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
COLLEGE DEGREES WHO CAN
SPEECH ENGLISH AND WHO HAVE
JOB SKILLS THAT ARE NEED.
NO COUNTRY ON EARTH HAS
12 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND GIVE
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP TO
THE CHILDREN OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Tucker: I'M FOR ANY
PROGRAM THAT ADMITS MORE
PEOPLE LIKE YOU INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT, WOULDN'T YOU THINK THAT
DEMOCRATS WOULD BE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU?
I MEAN IF THEY'RE
PRO-IMMIGRANT, I IMAGINE YOU
MUST BE GETTING CALLS FROM
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS JUST
THANKING YOU FOR EXPRESSING
YOUR OPINION.
HAVE YOU?
>> WELL, I'M A REPUBLICAN.
BUT I RESPECT A LOT OF
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS.
SO, I THINK THAT FOR ONE
THING IS UNITED STATES HAS
12 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
NO OTHER COUNTRY ON EARTH
HAS 12 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND GIVES
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP TO
THE CHILDREN OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
IF YOU LOOK AT CANADA AND
AUSTRALIA, THEY HAVE A
MERIT-BASED IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM THAT GIVES PRIORITY
TO THOSE WITH COLLEGE
DEGREES, ENGLISH-SPEAKING
SKILLS AND JOB SKILLS THAT
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR
ECONOMY.
SO THEY HAVE VERY FEW
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
IF YOU CARED ABOUT YOUR
COUNTRY, I WOULD HAVE A
SYSTEM LIKE THAT.
IT WOULDN'T EVEN BE A
QUESTION.